SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT IN A
MULTIDECADE CAREER.
LET'S GO OUT FRONT.
>>> GOOD EVENING, I'M ERIN
BURNETT.
OUT FRONT TONIGHT, OUSTED.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MORE THAN
100 YEARS -- IN MORE THAN A
CENTURY -- AN OFFICIAL IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN BARRED
FROM HOLDING OFFICE AND BARRED
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION'S BAN FOR
INSURRECTIONS.
THE FOUNDER OF THE COWBOYS FOR
TRUMP, ROY GRIFFIN TO BE REMOVED
FROM HIS POSITION AS COUNTY
COMMISSION, HE'S BEEN CONVICTED
OF PARTICIPATING IN THE JANUARY
6th RIOT.
THE COURT CONCLUDED THAT JANUARY
6th, 2021, MR. GRIFFIN BECAME
DISQUALIFIED UNDER SECTION 3 OF
THE 14th AMENDMENT FROM SERVING.
ACCORD TOGETHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, GRIFFIN WAS THERE ON
THE CAPITOL STEPS, WELL WITHIN
THE RESTRICTED AREA ON JANUARY
6th WHEN HE MADE THIS VIDEO.
>> THE PEOPLE HAVE SHOWN THAT
THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH.
THE PEOPLE ARE READY FOR FAIR
AND LEGAL ELECTIONS, OR THIS IS
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET MORE OF IT.
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GET AND YOU'RE GOING TO GET MORE
OF IT.
THIS IS, THOUGH, A HISTORY
MAKING DECISION BY THIS JUDGE.
THE LAST TIME A PUBLIC OFFICIAL
WAS REMOVED BASED ON THIS CLAUSE
OF THE 14th AMENDMENT WAS IN
1869.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO THE LIBERAL
WATCH DOG GROUP WHICH TOOK PART
IN THE LAWSUIT.
GRIFFIN TELLS VICE NEWS, QUOTE,
ALL THEY'RE DOING WITH ME IS
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK TO DO THIS
WITH OTHER PEOPLE INCLUDING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT IS THE BIG QUESTION
TONIGHT, WHETHER THE HISTORY
MAKING MOVE IN NEW MEXICO, THE
COUNTY COMMISSIONER, IS THIS THE
BUTTERFLY FLAPPING ITS WINGS, IT
BECOMES THE HURRICANE.
IS THAT WHAT ENDS UP MOVING THE
NEEDLE ON DONALD TRUMP.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT CALLED
PEOPLE LIKE ROY GRIFFIN TO
WASHINGTON, SUMMONED THEM TO
VIOLENCE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS STILL
DEFENDING WHAT HAPPENED THAT
DAY.
>> I MET WITH AND I'M
FINANCIALLY SUPPORTING PEOPLE
THAT ARE INCREDIBLE AND THEY
WERE IN MY OFFICE TWO DAYS AGO.
IT'S VERY MUCH ON MY MIND.
IT'S A DISGRACE WHAT THEY'VE
DONE TO THEM.
IF I DECIDE TO RUN AND IF I WIN,
I WILL LOOK VERY, VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT PARDONS, FULL PARDONS.
>> AND THAT'S NOW.
IT COMES AS WE'RE LEARNING MORE
TODAY ABOUT ATTEMPTS BY TRUMP
AND HIS SUPPORTERS TO OVERTURN
THE 2020 ELECTION.
THERE'S MORE TO BE LEARNED.
IT KEEPS COMING UP.
CNN OBTAINING SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
WHICH SHOWS A LOCAL REPUBLICAN
OFFICIAL ESCORTING TWO PRO TRUMP
OPERATIVES IN A COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICE.
THAT TOOK PLACE ON THE VERY SAME
DAY A VOTING SYSTEM IN THAT
OFFICE WAS BREACHED.
THE OFFICIALS SEEN ON CAMERA IS
UNDER CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION FOR
POSING AS A FAKE ELECTOR IN THE
2020 ELECTION.
EVAN PEREZ IS OUT FRONT LIVE IN
WASHINGTON.
I PREFACED THIS AS IS THIS THE
BUTTERFLY FLAPPING ITS WINGS.
WHAT COULD THIS RULING IN MEXICO
MEAN FOR OTHER PRO TRUMP
OFFICIALS WHO HELPED HIM TRY TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
>> IT'S SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE AT LEAST ATTEMPTED IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THIS GROUP, WHICH IS
CITIZENS FOR RESPONSIBILITY AND
ETHICS IN WASHINGTON, THEY HAVE
TRIED, AND OTHER GROUPS HAVE
TRIED TO DISQUALIFY OTHER PEOPLE
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN
GEORGIA, IN NORTH CAROLINA,
TRYING TO USE THE FACT THAT THEY
VOTED OR THEY TRIED TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION RESULTS TO TRY TO
HAVE THEM DISQUALIFIED FROM
OFFICE.
THOSE EFFORTS HAVE FAILED.
IN THIS CASE THE JUDGE SIMPLY
SAID THAT WHAT HE DID, WHAT
GRIFFIN DID WAS ESSENTIALLY
GRIFFIN.
HE CITED THAT HIS INVOLVEMENT IN
THE STOP THE STEAL MOVEMENT
WHERE GRIFFIN TALKED ABOUT THIS
IS A WAR TO KEEP FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN OFFICE.
HE CITED THE AS A MATTER OF FACT
THAT HE SEEMS TO HAVE NO REGRETS
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS DOING.
THIS IS A UNIQUE SITUATION THAT
HAPPENED IN NEW MEXICO.
WE ALSO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO THIS
SUMMER DECLINED TO CERTIFY THE
ELECTION RESULTS IN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION IN NEW MEXICO.
THAT'S ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
LED TO THIS DECISION BY THIS
JUDGE IN NEW MEXICO.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THOSE SAME
CIRCUMSTANCES WILL APPLY IN
OTHER CASES BECAUSE, KEEP IN
MIND, HE WAS PRESENT AT THE
JANUARY 6th RIOT.
THAT'S THE OTHER PART OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT I THINK PLAYED
INTO THIS JUDGE'S DECISION,
ERIN.
>> EVAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO TO ELIE HONIG, CNN'S
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST AND
STEPHANIE GRICH SHAM, FORMER
PRESS SECRETARY FOR THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LET ME START WITH YOU AS EVAN IS
EXPLAINING THIS.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS RULING
THAT COY GRIFFIN, A COUNTY
COMMISSIONER, IS NOW BARRED FROM
HOLDING OFFICE SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF HIS ROLE ON JANUARY
6th CITING THE CONSTITUTION?
>> ERIN, IT'S HISTORICALLY
SIGNIFICANT.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A JUDGE MAKE A
RULING LIKE THIS OR A POLITICIAN
BE DISQUALIFIED UNDER THE 14th
AMENDMENT GOING BACK OVER 100
YEARS.
THE 14th AMENDMENT WAS PASSED
DURING RECONSTRUCTION AFTER THE
CIVIL WAR IN 1868.
IT WAS RATIFIED.
THE IDEA WAS LET'S KEEP
CONFEDERATES AWAY FROM HOLDING
OFFICE.
UNDERSTAND, THIS IS NOT OVER.
THEIR ABSOLUTELY WILL BE AN
APPEAL.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS E, YES, THE
14th AMENDMENT TELLS US THAT ANY
PUBLIC OFFICIAL WHO ENGAGES IN
INSURRECTION IS DISQUALIFIED
FROM HOLDING FUTURE PUBLIC
OFFICE.
THE CONSTITUTION DOESN'T TELL US
WHO HAS TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION.
IS IT CONGRESS?
IS IT STATE LEGISLATURES?
IS IT FEDERAL JUDGES?
IS IT A STATE JUDGE LIKE WE SAW
IN THIS GRIFFIN CASE?
IS IT A JURY?
ALL THIS REMAINS AN UNKNOWN.
IT'S A CERTAINTY THAT GRIFFIN
WILL APPEAL.
THIS IS THE FARTHEST ANY OF
THESE CASES HAVE GOTTEN IN WELL
OVER A CENTURY.
>> AS YOU POINT OUT,
HISTORICALLY SIGNIFICANT.
STEPHANIE, THE REALITY OF IT IS,
EVERY TIME SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS -- I'M THINKING LIKE
THIS, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
EXTREMELY UNUSUAL, HASN'T
HAPPENED IN 100 YEARS.
YOU HAVE ONE PART OF THE COUNTRY
SAY FINAL, FINAL SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING, AND THEN THE OTHER
PART, THE TRUMP LOYAL
SUPPORTERS, THEY GET EVEN MORE
ENERGIZED, JUST LIKE MAR-A-LAGO.
YOU GET THE SENSE OF MAR-A-LAGO
AND THEY'RE MORE ENERGIZED.
HOW MUCH WOULD ANY KIND OF A
LEGAL EFFORT OR MORE LEGAL
EFFORTS LIKE THIS FOR OTHER
TRUMP-BACKED OFFICIALS WHO
BACKED TRUMP OR TRUMP HIMSELF,
ANY EFFORTS TO BLOCK HIM FROM
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN, HOW
MUCH WOULD THAT JUST ENERGIZE
HIS BASE?
>> I FIND THE ENTIRE THING
FASCINATING.
IN LISTENING TO ELIE, TOO, THAT
GAVE A LOT OF CONTEXT, OF COURSE
IT WILL ENERGIZE THE BASE.
IT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT TRUMP
AND ALL HIS MINIONS TO DECIDE TO
PLAY VICTIM AND FUNDRAISE OFF
OF.
I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT, WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO CHASE THE BASE'S
MIND.
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO CHANGE THAT
MAGA EXTREMIST SECTION OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING.
EVEN FOR ME, I THOUGHT
IMMEDIATELY AS A CITIZEN, WOW,
THAT SHOWS THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES TO YOUR ACTIONS,
THE FACT HE WAS AT THE JANUARY
6th SIEGE ON THE CAPITOL AND NOW
THERE ARE SOME REAL
CONSEQUENCES.
AND I THINK THAT WILL REALLY
RESONATE MAYBE WITH INDEPENDENT
VOTERS AND MAYBE CENTER RIGHT
VOTERS.
>> ELIE, COY GRIFFIN TOLD VICE
NEWS, HE SAID IN PART, ALL
THEY'RE DOING WITH ME IS LAYING
THE GROUNDWORK TO DO THIS WITH
OTHER PEOPLE INCLUDING PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK OUT
THERE, ELIE, ABOUT THAT, WHETHER
THERE'S GOING TO BE A PUSH TO
BAN TRUMP USING THE SAME THING
OR WHETHER HE WOULD DO SOME SORT
OF A PLEA RELATED TO WHAT IS
GOING ON AT MAR-A-LAGO WHICH
WOULD INVOLVE NOT RUNNING FOR
OFFICE AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS GOES?
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S RIGHT.
I DO THINK THAT OTHER GROUPS
WILL TRY TO USE THE 14th
AMENDMENT TO DISQUALIFY OTHER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND OFFICE
HOLDERS.
EVAN ALLUDED TO THIS IN THE
OPENING, TO DISQUALIFY MARGERIE
TAYLOR GREEN AND MADISON
CAWTHORN IN NORTH CAROLINA.
THIS INDIVIDUAL, GRIFFIN, HE
PLED GUILTY TO ONE OF THE
JANUARY 6th CASES.
WHAT HE PLED GUILTY TO WAS
TRESPASS, THAT'S IT.
A MISDEMEANOR.
WHAT THE JUDGE DID IN THIS CASE,
THE STATE JUDGE IN NEW MEXICO,
LOOKED AT ALL THE FACTORS,
LOOKED AT THE VIDEO AND SAID,
YES, HE PLED GUILTY TO TRESPASS,
BUT I LOOK AT ALL THE FACTS AND
CONCLUDE THIS IS INSURRECTION OR
REBELLION.
IT'S STILL A LONG SHOT.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT ALL THIS STANDS
UP AND IS APPLIED MORE BROADLY
TO HIGHER RANKING FEDERAL
OFFICIALS INCLUDING DONALD
TRUMP.
YOU CAN BET THIS WILL SPUR ON,
NO PUN INTENDED WITH COWBOYS FOR
TRUMP, INSPIRE FUTURE EFFORTS TO
TRY TO DISQUALIFY OTHERS.
>> STEPHANIE, IT IS IN THE
CONTEXT OF MANY SUPPORTERS OF
TRUMP WONDERING HOW PERMANENT
THE LAW AND ALL THIS WILL BE
BAUGS JUDGE HASN'T JUST PRAISED
THE MEMBERS OF THE MOBS THAT
STORMED THE CAPITOL, HE PROMISED
PARDONS.
HERE HE IS JUST RECENTLY.
>> IF I RUN AND IF I WIN, WE
WILL TREAT THOSE PEOPLE FROM
JANUARY 6th FAIRLY.
WE WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY.
AND IF IT REQUIRES PARDONS, WE
WILL GIVE THEM PARDONS.
>> JANUARY 6th DEFENDANTS ARE
HAVING THESE LIVES TOTALLY
DESTROYED AND BEING TREATED
WORSE THAN TERRORISTS AND
MURDERERS.
IF I BECOME PRESIDENT, SOME DAY,
IF I DECIDE TO DO IT, I WILL BE
LOOKING AT THEM VERY, VERY
SERIOUSLY FOR PARDONS.
>> IT'S A DISGRACE WHAT THEY'VE
DONE TO THEM.
IF I DECIDE TO RUN AND IF I WIN,
I WILL BE LOOKING VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT PARDONS, FULL PARDONS.
>> STEPHANIE, HOW MUCH OF AN
IMPACT ARE THOSE WORDS HAVING
RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, THEY DISGUST ME.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT RIGHT NOW.
AGAIN, IT GOES BACK TO WHAT I
SAID EARLIER, I BELIEVE THAT IS
SOMETHING HE'S SAYING TO RILE UP
THE BASE.
HE'S GETTING OUT IN FRONT OF
THAT CROWD.
THEY LOVE TO HEAR THAT KIND OF
TALK, THAT KIND OF RHETORIC,
LOVE TO HEAR HIM ACT LIKE HE'S A
KING AND BANDY ABOUT PARDONS
LIKE THEY'RE NOT THAT BIG A
DEAL.
IN THE END I HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT WOULD BACK FIRE.
IF THAT WERE TO BECOME A
NOMINEE, THAT WOULDN'T SIT WELL
WITH WOMEN VOTERS, CENTER VOTERS
AND INTO DENTS.
YOU CANNOT TREAT PARDONS LIKE
IT'S CANDY YOU PASS OUT AT